I don't spend much time like Googling
myself or anything but Lupita Nyong'o is
well aware of those Janelle Monae
romance rumors and she's decided to set
the record straight that is a really
great question the Oscar winner speaks
out inside Rolling Stone where Janelle
who came out as pansexual in 2018 is the
cover star for the mags Pride issue me
I'm on the cover as Lupita tells it
she's not surprised by the dating rumors
yeah there's been chatter since this
night when the two first met at the 2014
Met Gala Lupita chalks it up to
Janelle's magnetism and hey people
aren't curious about enigmatic people
when I see people I see your energy yes
I don't see like how you identified
totally and I feel like that opens you
up to fall in love with any beautiful
spirit that said Lupita stopped short of
outright denying their relationship has
gone further than just friends she says
I don't mind being associated with
Janelle in any capacity there's room for
interpretation she adds just because
you're a close friend of hers doesn't
mean you get to know everything about
her
okay
foreign
even though she's mysterious Janelle's
collaborators say her truth lives in the
work what's the magic of Janelle Monae I
think just her authenticity and her
expression of self and her bravery she's
an amazing woman Chanel lives honestly
and she lives out loud I never got to
meet David Bowie but she reminds me of
kind of like what I imagine he was like
living through her art meanwhile
Lupita's loving out loud
making her romance with TV host Sal
masakayla Instagram official in December
no
Lupita's caption we just click
as for Janelle she's very comfortable
keeping her love life out of the
spotlight back in the profile the singer
reveals that is part of my life that I
want to keep private I can talk about
all things Janelle Monae without having
to go into detail it's not necessary
I've been playing a version of of some
parts of me but now I'm owning all of me
this comes after Janelle's red table
talk appearance last year where she got
candid about her identity somebody said
if you don't work out the things that
you need to work out
first yeah for your share with the world
right you've been working it out with
the world yeah I'm non-binary yeah so I
just don't see myself as a woman or
solely or you know I feel all of my
energy I feel like God is so much bigger
than the human or the Sheep I had to own
all of me to really be able to talk
about it publicly I did what I could and
that's what life was about you show up
you do everything that you can and you
move on
[Music]